the new year is in full swing and now is
a great time to take a look at where
you're spending money and finding ways
to save here to help us is Tech expert
Liz Molly from Verizon who are the
sponsors of this next segment welcome to
the show it's great to have you here
thanks I'm excited to be here okay first
question how can you get more out of
your plan yeah so the new year is a
great time for a fresh start and to set
goals in all aspects of life and how to
save money so for a limited time with
your wireless bill
you can sign up for our welcome
unlimited offer okay it's unlimited talk
text and data it's only 25 a line and
that price isn't just for 2023 it's
guaranteed for three years so you're
locked in for three years you get all
that to all unlimited stuff for how much
25 25 huge yeah it's huge how can
Verizon how do you guys help us manage
all of our streaming services yeah so
um if you happen to be paying for Hulu
Disney Plus or ESPN Go on yes we have
something that we recently launched
called Plus a so plus play is an online
subscription management service that
allows you to see everything in one
place it also has additional perks like
free trials special discounts right now
we have an exclusive offer with Peloton
okay so you can get four months of the
Peloton app for free that deal does
expire today so sign up fast okay do
that right now this is all huge stuff
and I think Peloton I think Fitness I
think people have their New Year's goals
it's getting fit uh in 2023 how you have
some gadgets to help people stay fit and
kind of stay on yeah so the first thing
I have for the New Year's a new 5G
smartphone this is the Samsung Galaxy Z
flip 4. it might take you back to the
day where you had some foldable phones
it's compact fits in your pocket you can
use the quick shot to take photos and
video whenever this is the latest thing
ever so yeah this is so you're you're
folding it's a regular smartphone yeah
but you're flipping the thing you're
fully in your pocket yeah it's super
cool and this device pairs great with
the Google pixel watch okay it will be a
robust technology coach to help achieve
those fitness goals
stress goals sleep tracking it's got
heart rate monitoring if you can wear
the device to bed and it will tell you
how long you've slept as well as the
quality and you can ask Google to play
some sleep noises you know rain
thunderstorm
I always need a sound machine yeah I
forget I can tell my watch play sound
machine you'll get that white noise yep
brilliant okay we actually have one more
thing here before we wrap up yeah this
is actually our home internet when
you're on one of our unlimited plans you
qualify for Verizon home internet for
only 25 a month that's all included no
data caps no equipment charges so some
people are spending more than 100 a
month on their home internet service so
this is a great value okay on Verizon my
wife and I have been Verizon for a long
time I'm just hearing about this I love
this yes what a deal this is Liz you're
full of deals and great things thank you
so much for joining us we appreciate it
yeah you're welcome all right listen
well check this out by the way the QR
code is the best way to find a Verizon
store where you can check out these
great devices and and all these huge
savings for the new year for more
information visit verizon.com stores Las
Vegas now we'll be right back
[Music]